welcome back to the David pakman show I
am Jesse dollar more sitting in for
David while he is away
let's let's talk about a common refrain
a common turn of phrase that I use and
that is a dignity free performance
I am baffled by Republicans especially
election deniers out there who are
Shameless in their efforts and uh
and Shameless just in general about
their lies and their predictions and
everything else that just never comes
true and Mike pillow as David likes to
call him the my pillow goof Mike Lindell
he is maybe Chief among them
in the dignity free performance category
he was on he was on Jimmy Kimmel and it
was a remarkable like what is this guy
doing
sometimes when you watch him it's just
so perplexing that he's I think this
guy's a True Believer and then sometimes
he does other things I'm just I don't
understand it so let's let's put our
heads together here and watch this
Jimmy Kimmel stuffed him into a a fake
prop claw machine and made him do his
appearance on the show from the machine
and he went along with it
watch this
all the colorful unhinged characters
who've come to prominence in the
political era of Donald Trump our next
guest is probably the most enthusiastic
to help him overcome his debilitating
fear of machines we have installed him
inside a claw machine for his interview
tonight and joining us now from the
corner of Donkey Kong and Qbert the my
pillow guy Mike Lindell hello Mike
Timmy crumble is that you it's me
well Mike first question Mike is why do
you think people don't take you
seriously well you know I want to tell
you this Jimmy remember we were kids and
uh we questioned these carnival games
whether they were rigged or not yeah
right but when we spoke up back then we
didn't get sued did we no that's right
hey Mike get rid of that kid will you
give him a toy or something like that
there you go you got a winner it's a big
game
Mike I know that you're distrustful of
machines now that you're inside one do
you feel differently no same thing
there's their computers can be rigged
out there absolutely in elections you
know that did you ask Donald Trump uh
whether you should do this or not do you
run this sort of thing by him no I
didn't Jimmy I did this all my own I
wanted to be on your show you you know
you kept telling me to come on but you
you know I see the monologue there you
said it's because to put me in here
because I was wasn't vaccinated you
tricked me you did it to to be funny huh
no I didn't no I didn't want you in
there because you weren't vaccinated I
don't know to be honest I don't even
remember why I decided you should be in
there just don't you set it on yourself
it seemed like a good idea when it
happened I have to say I was very
surprised when you said you would do it
but you know I put it out there and so
you said yes so I you know I'm honoring
that commitment that I made on the air
I mean oof comes to mind cringe comes to
mind embarrassing humiliating all of
these terms what is he doing
he's not bolstering the case that he's
correct he's he he's he's creating a
situation where any credibility there
was none anyway that he may have had
it's just
like Dust in the Wind
bizarre to be sure
you may remember that a few years ago uh
the show got hacked and many thousands
of dollars were stolen we never got it
back it's a terrible feeling it can
happen to anyone but a couple of years
ago we got Aura which really gives us
significantly more peace of mind and our
sponsor Aura is the app that protects
you from scammers by alerting you
anytime your info like email passwords
social security number are found in data
breaches or also automatically requests
removal of your info from search engines
and it can reduce spam calls Aura alerts
you quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below